the Swedish Embassy in Iraq's Capital
Baghdad has been stormed by hundreds of
protesters and set on fire the
government of Iraq and Sweden have both
condemned the incident there's been
anger over the burning of a Quran by a
man in Sweden last month
let's go to our correspondent Mahmoud
Abdul Wahid who's live for us in
nasseria Mahmoud talk us through exactly
what's happening there
[Music]
will late on Wednesday supporters of uh
started gathering in front of the
Swedish Embassy in the capital Barda
despite the barricades and the concrete
blocks that were set last month during
their first protest and storming of the
Swedish Embassy in Baghdad but they
tried they filtrate infiltrated and they
gathered started scaling on the walls
and the Storm at the embassy and set
fire to parts of the embassy now
security forces have been deployed in
the area and the angry protesters were
trying to prevent civil defense teams
the firefighters from reaching the
embassy to extinguish the fire now both
foreign Ministries in Iraq and Sweden
have condemned the attack on the Sweden
on the Swedish side the photo Ministry
stated that Iraq's government Iraqi
forces or highlighted that Iraqi forces
should protect the Diplomatic missions
on the Iraqi side the foreign Ministry
has condemned the attack and stated that
the government has instructed Security
Forces to conduct a switch a swift
investigation and to disclose Those
Behind the the storming as you know that
this is against the or protesting
against the burdening of the Quran in
fact against another planned burning of
the Quran the protesters say that they
blame the Swedish government for what
they consider approving that protest
that is planned to be stated today
Thursday in front of the Iraqi Embassy
in Stockholm to Stage another burning of
the Quran
right so just to be clear more Quran
burning incidents are expected
well uh if that happens we will
definitely witness more uh violence in
the streets in Baghdad and probably in
other provinces across Iraq as you know
these angry processors have been
threatening in fact they have been uh
calling on the government to expel or to
dismiss the Swedish diplomatic Mission
from Iraq and they have been threatening
to also to take matters into their own
hands and to Stage a violent protests in
the streets if any more burnings happen
to the Quran